[Applause]
you are very cute and beautiful T today
look we didn't even call each other yes
you were feeling Earth Tones I was
feeling how are your chickens last time
you were here we were talking about your
chickens let's get to the serious Stu
get right to the nitty gritt yes well um
the chickens moved to the family farm in
Oklahoma oh my bunnies I talked to you
about now live in Montana my my Ranch in
Montana okay yes it's better for them
they're happier yeah and yes each of
them went and I felt a little bit guilty
about this but each of them went in
their own little to-go box I was a
little bit like don't think too much
about this chicken you're not nuggets
it's nugget and they all had a little
bit of food on the plane with a little
bit of benad dril in
there but this a tiny bit of um I love
that though that's fun living on a farm
that's better they are they they don't
lay eggs anymore they're post menopausal
um but you know what they
I know but they still have value and
they're still smart lovely ladies they
are relevant um no I have to ask this
too because I just moved here and I love
it I'm so happy you love it your kids
like it I love it my kids love it we
love it here but you moved here and you
were pretty young and what was that
first move like I moved here so I
graduated from college I worked at a
Shakespeare Festival I was doing like
summer stock theater you know like you
know cleaning the toilets and building
the sets and all of this that's cool a
the the Georgia Shakespeare where I
worked there was a musical there that
went to a strip mall in Florida and I
went with the musical and so I worked
there and then I came up here to um
audition for Utah Shakespeare you can
tell I wanted to do like St be on stage
and when I got here a friend said hey
here's a backstage you should go check
this out so I checked it out I went on
auditions I got three jobs that first
day as like I think I just walked in and
I was like hi my name's Jim I'm from
West Virginia i' like to act you know I
want to do this they just kept being
like okay let's see what you can do so
somebody said you should meet with an
agent anyway I ended up living here I
was under studying a t play a month in
the country at the roundabout yeah and I
lived on a woman's kitchen floor a woman
that I found off the bulletin board at
actor Equity as you do as one does and
there was a futon in my suitcase and
like tucked into the corner were futons
yeah yeah and I live there for a couch
and a bed how helpful is that I never
folded it up it was just a little
mattress in the corner yeah no I lived
on a mattress in someone's house in La
that was kind of similar I think when
you have a big dream you just are
willing to accept whatever comes your
way like to get there yeah it didn't
even phase me honest I was thrilled no
me too I was excited that is funny
looking back I'm just like what in the
world like if my kid was like I'm going
to do this but I at the time was just
like living my best life yeah it did not
even occur to me to feel weird that I
was living no I was thrilled and I don't
think I think we get too precious about
things now and i' had M I couldn't the
subway token to get toare I walked back
and I made $150 a week and I worked too
much to do real shifts at the restaurant
and somehow I just survived I just made
it work yeah yeah that's awesome I love
people hearing that too because you're
so successful so those people killing it
right now like there is light at the end
of the tunnel you know if you really
know I think it is enjoying the Journey
of it and letting yourself be where you
are and not just looking ahead looking
ahead like I'll be happy when I'll be
happy when I get into this college or
when I am married or when this happens
or I'm a whatever I just was like pretty
psyched to be right there um so whenever
um whenever you were talking about
Shakespeare I heard is that the cast
that you did laundry for is that did you
lose a bit like like you did you did
okay so in the process of all of this
when I worked at this strip mall um I
was non-e Equity but I was an outof Town
um person and I think I was making just
like $100 a week but it was I was
professionally acting you know what I
mean and and I couldn't have another job
at the same time and so the owner of the
theater he said well what are you going
to what are you going to do how are you
going to afford to live down here and I
said I can do anything I can clean I can
I can do laundry and I said that's why
you're successful you accept it like I
can work for it oh it didn't even bu
just said I can do laundry so there were
35 people in the cast most 35 men in the
cast and I washed and ironed all 35
dress shirts um between every show eight
shows a week and I did that the whole
time and he let me be a roommate to
another person in one of the I'm glad
people are hearing that too I was cuz
you know why I hate whenever I I rent
into especially musician no because I I
rent into a certain musicians like you
know throughout my career and they're
just like oh I don't I can't get a job
I'm like there's a Starbucks right down
the road like there's a Target right
like what are you doing and they're too
proud to go get a job that they think is
beneath them and I'm like do you know
where all I've worked yeah like do you
know how many jobs I have I I feel lucky
that that wasn't in my way I didn't get
my that either and I thought it was
hilarious I mean and by the way can I
just be real here for a second the
amount of times I sent 35 men on stage
in slightly damp very wrinkle shirts
throw it in dry with at the wrong I mean
I was just like sorry I mean I
was yeah I don't think I could do it now
I don't iron well I've never ironed girl
throw it in the JY with a damp towel
anyway so you gets the wrinkle right out
that was a look at her new movie Family
switch you can catch it now on Netflix
so explain every the movie is hilarious
explain to everybody what's going on the
movie is so much fun it's really just
you know like all body switch movies
it's about walking a mile in someone
else's shoes it's impossible to know
what your kids are going through what
your parents are going through unless
you can actually be them for a day and
it's you know just a lot of fun just in
this case we all switch Ed switches with
Brady who plays our son Brady noon Ed
Helms Ed Love Ed yeah we love it the
baby and the dog switch to just to add a
little chaos so it's it's the that's my
favorite part and and it has a little
bit of a holiday feel it's the most fun
heartwarming funny if you have Ed Helms
in a movie you're golden and by the way
these kids outshine the two of us they
are amazing amazing I love that yeah do
you love playing mom cuz I've seen you
in a lot of movies where you're playing
a mom do you love playing the mom role
cuz you do it well I really do yeah I
must be working something out because I
keep playing mother daughter yeah yeah
no it's awesome though we're I'm telling
you my family is obsessed like yesterday
it I'm telling you that movie changed my
whole family Dynam like literally
they're like can we have a yes day we've
had so many yes days like well this is
the same producing team we started this
process while we were on set making yday
we were just like oh oh what else can we
can what else can we do it's also
Loosely comes from an Amy Krauss
Rosenthal book which she blessed her
soul also wrote yesterday this was
bedtime for Mommy about a little girl
putting her mom to bed her parents to
bed and they don't want to go to bed and
they're we want another glass of water
we want this so it's just kind of that
switching idea yeah I love it yeah my
kids are going to be obsessed with this
one too I'm I'm wondering what because
there's like a dance an annual dance
thing that your character does there's a
dance yeah there's a dance everyone will
be doing it we have Beth nicely came and
choreographed for us and it is she's a
former rocket a Broadway dancer and we
had a blast all except for Ed hels Bless
yeah yeah yeah oh he didn't dance he
danced oh no he danced he should get
credit for every single step he just was
like this is
awful I am so miserable but he worked so
so hard well that's the best Keys takes
I know between takes I would look back
and we'd be shooting something weeks
away from the dance and he would have
his nose facing a wall just like five
six seven eight yeah just wanting to
nail it he y just wanting to get through
do you have your own like family
traditions like that because we have I
literally just had a dance party to
share's new Christmas song DJ play a
Christmas song because it's the greatest
Christmas song ever um but we had one
last night at my house we have dance
parties all the time do you do anything
like that in your house I mean we do all
kinds of things during Co I talked my
kids into making videos with me sure and
nothing else to do it was so they were
so fun and then they kind of got that I
was more into them than they were and
that was it then it became not cool yeah
then it be was not cool anymore and then
they were like pulled the but yes this
this character has an annual Christmas
song and dance video that they do for
Christmas as their Christmas card I love
that that's so great well um Jennifer is
also a founding investor of the Angel
City Football Club the women's soccer
team in Los Angeles which is so cool but
I think that's awesome we're going to
get to that but here there she is at
another soccer match here you
go you're the one yelling you're the one
yelling I'm yelling like I suddenly know
what's happening just cuz I'm an
investor in Angel City it's like I go to
Angel City I'm clueless I know I'm
clueless I just am smiling having a good
time I know I bits and pieces you know I
mean Abby wach and and Glen and doer
they tell me things I love them by way
AR they cool I know so I'm learning I'm
there a lot but as soon as I'm out and
I'm like my nephew's game in West
Virginia I'm suddenly an expert yelling
things you know hey rap that's a yellow
card I don't know
what I love that people at the game are
like is that no like really I grew up
with everyone at the game that's my high
school that's my sister my yeah that's
my town oh that's awesome they've all
known me they are not impressed family
is like a movie know it's awesome they
are not impressed I'm there um well
we're going to play a game next are you
ready you always beat me you always beat
me at games here you are very
competitive I am very competitive I'm
okay if I lose but I want to compete
heavily yeah okay all right ready let's
take a break all right we're going to
stretch it out Jennifer's movie Family
switch is on Netflix right now and we've
got the perfect game to honor next we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home